but I wanted you to talk about your
brother at the spa I didn't talk about
that you know we haven't open he told
that story on Cassim show but that's the
only time it's been heard oh really
Tiger Mask Lucy so I take my brother so
I go to this Korean spa one night my
brother goes we're in the car would
drive pulling into the spa and my
brother has his camera and he goes I'm
gonna flock this vlog I've got a vlog I
go what and bring it in I'm bringing the
camera in I got what dude it's gonna be
weird I don't care it's me great so we
go in and there's just naked Korean men
laying down and he's filming their dicks
oh yes he's panning around the [ __ ]
place he's got everything he's got
everything he should he sees my dick I
pull mine out purposely right I filmed
him getting undressed we were laughing
but then he brings it into the spa area
where the steam room and all that stuff
is and I'm in there taking a shower and
he's filming inside there and this
middle-aged Korean man who walks in
completely naked and my brother turns
his camera toward him and just tapes him
naked what'd the guy do the guy goes to
my brother goes um hi excuse me I know
that you're taping me um
I don't care what you're doing but the
last three seconds of that can you
delete it and my brother looks at him go
nah I don't do any of that [ __ ] and now
I'm like naked right uncomfortably other
side going stay so you're freaking out
yeah my brother's like you know his his
temper he's gonna go toe-to-toe with
this guy right and then I had to go grab
the camera and my brothers like you're
ruining it's a good flog we got good
stuff I were racing the whole thing and
I had to erase this vlog in front of
this guy right Oh Mike but imagine if I
wasn't there he could've died there's a
guy pissed he was livid and he wasn't
livid at first he was livid at my
brother's attitude whose understanding
at first at first is it can use
please delete the neck last three
minutes yeah but my brother is that nah
like he gets like really like
confrontational and urban thug thuggish
yeah you could not do any of that
like right in his face this is what he
texted me but Bob telling you about the
spy incident I said yeah he goes it was
a close call that Korean dude was so mad
I filmed his penis by accident is what
he said and then he and I and I put the
sweating emoji and he was kalila it was
a golden vlog yeah it was a great vlog I
love like every what time he tells it
he's like yeah I did it just for George
and I'm like no no I didn't tell you to
Kirk like film naked dudes I don't don't
blame me on this thing doesn't have that
kind of like sensibility like and that's
why I'm afraid that he's gonna get
himself in a situation where because of
his temper he's gonna get hurt
do you ever see that in him or no I
haven't seen it that's I hear about it
but I yeah I personally uh has that
caused some trouble in the past when you
were younger oh yeah I mean he got fired
from every job he's ever had because of
it oh it sounds even I can't be improv I
got him a job at Tempe improv and he
assaulted a waiter damn you got into a
fistfight with him not assaulted like
know you've like pushed a waiter you're
mean and the waiter goes what the [ __ ]
dude I just told you to run these potato
skins you know and my boys like don't
talk to me like that I'm just saying I'm
cute
did I get him a job at sushi Dan's on
sunset Oh Sudan yeah so I talked to Dan
Dan my brother he's like I don't know I
had pasta I thought he said to me you
know we're really busy I mean we could I
guess get that neat the hair up my
brothers are hardware I'm lying yeah
he's great he's a horrible word three
days later Bob I got fired why why Steve
I told the sushi stuff to go [ __ ]
himself
he told me to bring water to that table
record store
oh he didn't know why do you know why
oh I know I know exactly why he was in
the break room where people are women
are sitting there and my brother's
telling another guy yeah I had a pan
over and a [ __ ] was all over my dick
you know I mean I'm penetrating her you
know I mean so and all these girls are
going hum don't talk about it not [ __ ]
it
and I was fifty like he's like it's
sexual harassment you can't talk like
that um he this this was the old Steve
he would never act like this - no no I
don't believe it I think that he might
pop off because he has like rage
tendencies but I don't think that he
would he's he's got a lot more sense
about him now how do you know because I
I see him all the time I see him in
situations where he is getting better
yeah he is getting you're right he is
getting better there's a little growth
there but I'm still frightened sometimes
because it's like what he does when it
clicks though it clicks very it's it's
when you see it it's gonna it's gonna
shock you
[Music]